[Music]
I'm working on a novel it is a story of
my life and my sister's make it short
and spicy and if the main character is a
girl make sure she's married by the end
Wow
I want to be an artist in Rome and be
the best painter in the Lubar offs what
you want to isn't a Joe to be a famous
writer yes but it sounds so crass when
she says my girls have a way of getting
into mischief so do i this is Meg Amy
Beth in general I intend to make my own
way in the world no one makes their own
way least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well you are not married not well
that's because I'm rich
so would you like to dance with me I
can't because I scorched my dress and
you make told me to keep still so no one
would see it I have an idea of how we
can manage
Joe is a lost cause
so who are your families hope
I believe we'd have some power over who
we love it isn't something that just
happens to a person
[Music]
I think the poets night to sugery we can
leave right now I'll sell stories
John you here should be an actress and
you should have a life on the stage just
because my dreams are different than
yours doesn't mean they're unimportant I
told you ever since I've known you so I
couldn't help it a new play written by
Miss Joe moss
women they have minds and they have
souls as well as just hearts I want to
be great or nothing and they've got
ambition and they've got talent as well
as just beauty I'm so sick of people
saying that love is just all of them in
that's it for I'm so sick of it
[Music]
there are some majors - laughing - man
[Music]
so who does she marry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]